I really needed to turn over the reins
to to Bob to someone else that was
Robert Iger in 2020 when he stepped down
as CEO of Disney the company he led for
15 years two years later he's now back
after the board ousted Bob chapek
following week fourth quarter earnings
Disney stock rallied after the
announcement bringing back CEO is a
strategy that many companies have
attempted over the years some more
successfully than others this is how
three so-called Boomerang CEOs made
comebacks and how their companies fared
after their return a former CEO can help
revive a company's culture they're often
viewed as the face of the company they
often have Inspire the hearts and Minds
a lot of people will sometimes say Bob
Iger was someone that while he was not a
Founder people have described him as a
quasi founder in the sense that he was a
larger than life CEO like Iger Howard
Schultz was considered a popular CEO at
Starbucks you first step down as CEO in
2000 but returned to in 2008 as the
coffee chain sales slumped after Cost
Cuts Schultz got Starbucks to
profitability by the time he stepped
down again in 2017 Starbucks's stock was
up 640 percent but when he returned once
more in 2022 on an interim basis he
found a different company facing worker
dissatisfaction and pandemic consumer
shifts I came back to reinvent the role
and responsibility of a public company
at a time where there is a cultural and
political change Starbucks has said that
it will invest 1 billion dollars into
employees and store experience a
returning CEO or founder has to come
back to a different company so remember
someone else has been leading it for
usually a couple of years at least that
means the strategy has often shifted so
Spencer Stewart looked at across all
CEOs that were appointed at S P 500
companies since 2010 and 8 out of 13
permanent boomerang appointments did
worse during their second stint than
during their first stint Twitter's
co-founder Jack Dorsey was fired in 2008
in part for frequent absences the board
brought him back in 2015.
um they basically wanted to reassure
investors and the Hope was to revive the
social media company's sagging user
growth during his second run some
employees said he acted too slowly on
issues like hate speech harassment and
censoring Dorsey left the CEO post again
in 2021 during his second tenure Twitter
shares gained 63 percent while the
NASDAQ Composite more than doubled
Twitter and Dorsey did not immediately
respond to requests for comment when he
left he said in a statement that
Founders leading companies can be
severely limiting but Founders like
Dorsey are common Boomerang CEOs what we
often see is that CEOs who are either
Founders or really connected to
companies feel that it's their Duty
their service to make sure that they
come company succeeds one of the most
prominent examples from the late 90s is
Steve Jobs coming back to run Apple when
it was on the brink of bankruptcy
Jobs first left Apple in 1985. he
returned in 1997 as an advisor and
eventually took the CEO title I like a
lot of other people are pulling together
to help Apple get healthy again and I am
extraordinarily confident that that is
going to happen he quickly broker at a
surprise deal with Microsoft sending the
stock up and he brought apple back to
profitability within a year by the time
he stepped down in 2011 jobs had helped
turn Apple into a smartphone giant Apple
did not immediately respond to a request
for comment as for Iger he now has two
more years at the top at Disney
investors hope he can turn things around
despite the company's tumultuous year